if it's true as we said before that
politics is natural to the human being
that they always live under laws then it
arises from their gift of speech which
is the classical argument and also the
founders argument about government then
there's always going to be government
right and you're gonna be in the
government and it's going to have a
monopoly on force and it can't really do
anything unless you say it can and
that's not the Kings idea the Kings idea
is you're gonna have to have Kings it's
in the order of nature I was born to
this I'm gonna be the darn King and
you're gonna be the people and I'm
supposed to take care of you and you're
supposed to do what I say and that's not
grounded in the consent of either one of
us we have this dish and we're stuck
with it once you change that and you say
the government can really only do what
you say it can do that limits it
drastically I mean how does the
government established what's the first
step in the establishment of the
American government breaking away from
the government we were under happened in
the yeah okay that's good happened in
the we have a code it happened in the
what in the so we get the government
right now we've given consent is that
enough what else do we need wait because
we have to keep giving it right you have
to give consent to form the government
but then after that do you need more do
you need to be saying okay on an ongoing
basis because if you do you're gonna
need a Constitution what was Hitler's
constitutionally Kiley believe what I
say or die yeah yeah actually yeah I
don't expect you kids to read my books
so I can quote them
[Applause]
Hitler came to power in 1933 and Hitler
wouldn't take the job unless Hindenburg
and the leaders of the main political
parties would promise to support an
enabling act he called it that would
liberate the government to do whatever
it wanted to do Hindenburg was reluctant
about this and and Hitler very clever
man offered him something he says I
won't do anything that affects the
powers of the presidency in other words
the one person who won't
I won't touch as you and so Hindenburg
said okay right
that itself is a kind of violation of
consent right because end of the rule of
law because now they're not going to
live under the same law anymore right so
Hitler's Constitution as Hitler's will
and that'll work if one person gets to
make all the decisions but if a lot of
people are gonna make the decision
you're gonna have to have some form by
which they can indicate authoritative
Lee what they agree to so if you're
gonna involve a lot of people in the
government you're gonna have to have a
constitution you're gonna have and you
see why the constitution has to be
different from the things that that is
actually in the law because it
prescribes the process by which the
ordinary laws would be made it can't be
the same as they right so and that is by
the way implied right through the middle
of the deck boys benefit us when they
talk about the king messin with the
government all the time in the way that
he was doing you see so consent requires
representation and representation
requires a written way for that to
happen